[Music]
[Applause]
Jason Garrett football night in America
Studio analyst and uh three-time Super
Bowl champ with the Cowboys head coach
with the Cowboys back on the program
good to have you um when you were head
coaching the Cowboys and an assistant
would be asked by another team to
interview how does that process work as
the head coach with one of your
assistant coaches
you know I think you have to try to
facilitate it as best you can I don't
think the system is a great system
because there's no doubt there's some
distraction that's going to come with it
uh particularly you know these guys are
usually coming from playoff teams so
you're playing these playoff games and
guys are getting ready to do an
interview but you carve out some time
you know I thought the guys you know in
Detroit seem to do a good job with it
you know hey you got three hours on
Saturday you got a couple hours on
Friday that kind of thing but you know
the tricky part about it is you have to
prepare for the interviews and uh you
can't just go in there cold you're not
going to get the job so you have to
allocate some time in an already packed
week when you're a coach I mean every
minute is occupied from from you know
the the the start on Monday morning till
getting ready to go uh on the field on
Sunday so uh to carve out that time can
be a little
tricky what still bothers you about the
Lions loss
well they had it you know they played so
well you're up 247 with 30 minutes to go
you think that hey you know we should be
able we should be able to seal this deal
um you know there were a couple moments
there a lot of conversation about Dan
Campbell going forward on fourth down uh
in two occasions in the second half um a
big part of their success all year long
has been his belief and his
aggressiveness in his players and
they've responded well we'll never be
able to measure the residual impact of
that and how that helped them get there
having said that you know with seven to
go in the third quarter and you're up
2410 and you have the opportunity to
make it a three-score game that's the
one that I'm like
huh you know three scores is hard
psychologically two scores you say okay
we get a stop it's 2410 now we go drive
we're back in it and that's exactly what
happened you make it you make it 17
points and three scores all of a sudden
they're saying hey we got to score fast
and we got to stop them and if they
score again there's all these mental
gymnastics that you play so for me that
was an opportunity even though
aggressiveness has been good for them
that was an opportunity to kick go up by
three scores and then the one at the end
it's hard for me not to try to go for
the tie but when all that stuff starts
to unravel you know sometimes those
decisions you make as a coach can help
your team now if they go the right way
and they make those fourth Downs you
know they get the result that they want
but you can't lose sight of the fact
that they didn't play great defense in
the second half of the game San
Francisco went up and down the field and
I think that was the difference as well
this may sound obvious your answer but
I'll still pose it if you're the ners
are you more concerned about Patrick
momes or Kansas City's
defense
well ultimately you're more concerned
about Patrick Mahomes because what he's
done in big moments and big game is
really unprecedented in my view he
always seems to make the play to get him
to the games and then to win those games
so ultimately I think it will come down
to him but your points well made your
question's a great one they've played so
well on defense and you think God that
Ste bagn has done with a lot of young
guys on that defense really good on all
three levels
but you know you and I have talked about
this before about Kansas City I've been
so impressed with with how they've
gotten to this point you know they they
flopped around a lot this year and you
know they were looking for their
identity and and I I had a chance to do
that playoff game a few weeks ago the
real cold one against Miami and you know
they just had a look in their eye the
head coach did the quarterback did you
know the different guys we spoke to and
it just seemed to me a great example of
a team saying okay who can we trust who
can we trust on offense we can trust 15
we can trust 10 we can trust 87 we can
trust four and everybody else if they
get a if they get a chance to touch the
ball that's fine and and it's amazing
how when you do that those other guys
start to respond and uh to me it's been
a master class in coaching by Andy Reid
to win the way they've won the last
three weeks the last couple on the road
and and and to your point the defense
has a lot to to do with the two but I
loved how they've embraced their
identity on offense it's been fantastic
we're talking to Jason Garrett football
night in America analyst this whole game
manager thing has taken over with Brock
cie and I look I might be somebody who
led the charge on this years ago I
called Alex Smith a game manager but I
didn't mean it as a negative I mean you
were there with Troy Aman was Troy a a
game
manager yeah yeah I agree with you I
mean that's what quarterbacks are
supposed to do you're supposed to be
great decision makers throw the ball to
the right guy and make the kind of
decisions that help you win games and if
that's a game manager great it used to
be game manager and Gunslinger Troy a is
managing games and Brett Favre's a
gunslinger right you know and and and
when it goes sideways at the end of a
game because a gunslinger is trying to
stick a ball in there and it gets tipped
up in the air you know he was aggressive
he was ripping it in there you know I'd
rather try to win the game games and
that's what Troy was able to do for us I
absolutely love Brock pie and and and
and and the story of hey he's the last
pick in the draft that's fascinating I
love all that but this guy has played so
well for such a young guy to to walk in
I get it's a good environment I get they
have a good team Kyle does a fantastic
job I understand all that look at the
record of the backup quarterbacks in San
Francisco not named Jimmy Garoppolo the
last few years ain't real good so a lot
of guys can't simply just go in there
and play this guy's played at a high
level sometimes people have an agenda
when they evaluate and that always gets
them in trouble just watch what he's
done look at the production he's been
really impressive and he made the he
made the big plays in the game the other
day with his feet to allow them to win
that ball game yeah I know that's what I
think is lost on people that he he does
he doesn't have to do a lot of crazy
things or be a guns Slinger or uh you
know take a risk because of the talent
around him and when he does you know
when he's forced into making a play he
did make three plays with his with his
legs and and he looked quick when he was
making those plays so I I don't know
what role that plays in the Super Bowl
there but it feels like and I I remember
saying this to a couple of analysts he
might not get credit unless he wins two
Super Bowls like he wins one they'll go
yeah but hey with that team you know
like Brad Johnson or Trent dilford well
with that team if he wins a second one
then they'll go all right I think he's a
pretty good quarterback yeah and I think
that's an unfair standard I really do
and if you really watch how he plays if
you think about what the game manager
would be described as it would be one
two three throw it one two three throw
it one two three four five throw it the
guy's always open all you're doing is
making these decisions watch the plays
that he makes takes watch the touchdown
he throws to auk where he drops back
slides this way slides again and sticks
the ball in the hole between the two
Defenders obviously the plays that he
made with his feet at the end of the
game so this guy makes these kind of
sneaky plays he doesn't wue when he
walks in the room he looks like the
paper boy we get all that you know he's
not 64 220 you know shot out of a cannon
when he runs it and throws it we
understand that but watch him play
football he plays at a high level and he
has and young this is year two he's
really
impressive can you help me understand
what Jerry Jones is saying about Dak
Prescott so he says Dak has done nothing
to change my mind about any promise for
the future I think I've said that we
will go as far as Dak takes us in the
playoffs remember that we'll go as far
as Dak takes us and that's how far we
went we will go as far as Dak takes us
okay this is how far he took you you
didn't even get to a conference title
game so it it doesn't he may mean it as
a compliment Jason it doesn't sound like
a
compliment well let's go back to your
question about the
Chiefs why are the Chiefs dangerous they
got an amazing quarterback certainly the
best of his generation and they have a
fantastic
defense right wh why are the 49ers in in
the big game a lot of weapons on offense
quarterback plays really good they got a
fantastic defense so something I learned
a long time ago playing for the Cowboys
on those Super Bowl teams is teams win
now you have to have a great quarterback
quarterback play is critical but teams
win people forget that the teams in the
90s we had the number one defense in
football right we also had Troy aan EMT
Smith Michael irvan unbelievable
offensive line and go on and on and on
teams win in the NFL and and so this
idea that it's all on the quarterback
back to be able to take your team all
the way NFL's too good you can't do it
John Elway is probably the best example
for me for years he took the city of
Denver and went like this and put him on
his shoulders and took him to the
playoffs and had these bad Super Bowl
losses when they got better around them
they played better defense they got
Terell Davis all of a sudden you know
John Elway is John Elway so you you know
the idea that you're going to put it all
on the quarterback is unfair Dak didn't
play his best ball against Green Bay we
all know that the defense didn't play
their best ball either so teams win when
the Cowboys are able to win some of
these critical games as a team that's
when they're going to get that's we're
going to go uh where Jerry Jones wants
them to
go would you rather have Travis Kelce or
Rob
gronowski you always do this to me why
do you always do this to
me it was bich versus
Brady I I wait until the end of the
interview to bring this question fast
that's a
great so who would you rather have
Travis Kelce or Rob gronowski uh I'll
take Travis Kelce just by a hair both of
them are you know they're alltime great
their top five tight ends ever to play
both those guys so but tougher to defend
if you were if you were running the
defense here defending grank or Kelce
you know for for me I think it's more
challenging to defend Kelsey Ju Just
because
uh he's a little bit more
elusive I think he's probably a better
route Runner um and so you know that
matchup is hard but it's the same
problem you put grank over there his
size his ability to just go get a ball
is is really unprecedented at the
position so you know they're both
incredible players gun to my head I'll
take Kelsey that's probably because he
was 11 for 11 the other day in my most
recent memory but uh the they're both
incredible would you rather have Tom
Brady or Troy
Aman wow now you're killing me um I I I
I think Troy Aman is the most underrated
quarterback in ball I don't think people
realize how great this guy was and um
he's obviously a dear friend of mine we
had lockers next to each other for eight
straight years but I just think he's an
amazing amazing football player he um
I've never seen a guy put a team first
more than he did if you think about that
you know the temptation to make it all
about me yeah make it I'm the
quarterback of the Cowboys cash in uh
make it about my stats make it he made
it about winning and and if you think
about his postgame interviews anybody
who watched him do interviews for years
would say Troy Aman going to
broadcasting are you kidding me I mean
he's the he's he's like boring well he
was boring on purpose it was all
intentional because he was leading the
team and he was trying to limit the
distractions and so his leadership was
rare and then his ability to go out
there and play at the highest level in
the biggest moments was incredible um
now Tom Brady comes along and you say
Troy won three Thomas won seven you know
the the facts tell you that boy we got
you know Brady's This is the first face
we chisel on Mount Rushmore but uh so
okay gun to my head I take Brady but
Troy Aman could do anything that Tom
Brady could do in my opinion he's one of
the alltime greats yeah and I think
you're being fair to Troy when you say
and you know he had all these weapons
and I don't know he was probably labeled
a game game manager which maybe was a
negative to people but he did he managed
the game he had EMT you I mean why
wouldn't you share the wealth with
everything that you had there instead of
being one-dimensional let's throw it 40
times you guys LED with EMT and then you
know you needed a big play you had Irv
that you know would be there to get a
first down so I think to suppress your
ego at that position with that team is
even more challenging than what people
realize no no doubt no doubt and it's a
different time it's it's 25 30 years ago
now and and the world's crazy now with
with you know everything's so immediate
and and everything so so much in your
face just with how the media is but it
was wild back back then too I mean there
was a lot of attention given to that
team and he he led it so well and and
and I agree with what you said we always
LED with EMT but sometimes we LED with
Troy you know a typical Troy Aman game
was he's 15 for 19 at half for 180 yards
and two touchdowns and then he finishes
19 for 26 you know because we throw it
six times in the second half and we run
it more yeah so it wasn't always run run
run you know Troy fit in sometimes it
will start with the pass and then over
the course of the game we just wear him
down by doing both I'd like to make you
sweat a little bit you do a great job of
that that's why they call you the best
in the business and you thought coaching
the Cowboys was difficult come on come
on uh hey great to talk to you and uh
thanks for joining us as always jayon
yeah always enjoy it you're fantastic
have a great day that's Jason Garrett
NBC football night in America Studio
analyst of course peacock will be on
display at the Super Bowl our show pro
football talk with Florio and Chris Sims
uh Michael Smith and Michael Holly
brother from another Matthew Barry's
fantasy football happy hour all of that
coming from Vegas coming up next week